on appelle ça la ridiculation le fait de
réduire légèrement le format ou la
quantité d'un produit tout en continuant
de le vendre au même prix une pratique
de plus en plus courante la lessive les
choses comme ça je trouve que les
bouteilles sont moins remplies ou ça se
joue pas grand-chose
de 450 g sont tombés à 410 oui
absolument je pense même pas juste une
impression parce que je pense qu'il y en
a moins que ça coûte plus cher ce
phénomène existe depuis longtemps mais
la tendance à s'amplifier durant les
crises économiques la raison pour
laquelle est fabriquée font ça c'est
qu'on comme consommateur on est souvent
plus sensible au prix qu'à la quantité
des exemples de diminution du format
sans changement de prix
les pattes alimentaires le yogourt les
grignotines de la tartinade aux
noisettes et un classique de jus
d'orange
certains formats de crème glacée ont
également été tellement réduits qui sont
maintenant taxés lorsqu'on diminue la
quantité dans certains cas on va tomber
en format coloration en guillemets donc
ce qui produit qui auparavant ne
mettait pas de combien de produits sont
affectés par ce phénomène qui est
parfaitement légal personne ne le sait
sauf Statistique Canada qui pour mesurer
l'inflation compile les noms des marques
et produits touchés par la rééducation
mais tout en précisant qu'il s'agit
d'une information confidentielle moi je
pense ce qui devrait changer c'est de la
transparence si les entreprises
font de la rééducation il devrait le
dire et on a commencé à le voir on va
commencer ça fait quelques années là
c'est quelque chose de nouveau mais pour
le consommateur observez comparer le
prix des produits par gram ou
millilitres reste la meilleure façon de
savoir exactement ce qui se retrouve
dans son panier d'épicerie
on voit tous que la facture d'épicerie
augmente ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal
avec nous le spécialiste que vous
connaissez bien Sylvain Charlebois
directeur scientifique pour le
laboratoire de sciences analytique de
l'université dalousie halifac ce bonsoir
Monsieur Charlesbourg
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller comme ça
monsieur Charlebois dans la réduction du
volume pour garder à peu près les mêmes
prix
en fait là vous parlez d'un problème
pour essayer de la rééducation les
quantités diminuent les prix demeurent
les mains donc il y a plusieurs coxes
que vous venez de présenter mais il y a
un autre problème à tout ça il y a pour
certains produits selon l'Agence du
revenu du Canada il y a certains
produits qui sont tellement réduits qui
deviennent des collations et des
collations sont taxables votre exemple
de 5 bars au lieu de 6 dans une boîte là
à 6 ce n'est pas taxable à 5 c'est
taxable donc c'est un 15 % de plus à la
caisse puis souvent les gens s'en
aperçoit pas parce qu'ils regardent pas
le reçu c'est la face cachée de la
rééducation
qu'est-ce que ça effectivement la taxe
face cachée par ailleurs qu'est-ce qui
est mieux de qu'ils augmentent les prix
ou qui réduisent la quantité parce qu'on
pourrait dire
c'est peut-être une bonne chose si on
mange moins et puis c'est pas que des
bonnes choses pour la santé on aura
compris
qu'en est moins pour le même prix ça
coûte pas plus cher mais il y en a un
peu moins donc on a mangé moins quel est
votre vision sur où on s'en va avec ce
phénomène
d'abord c'est pas un nouveau phénomène
monsieur Roy ça la rééducation existe
depuis 40 ans mais il y a des cycles par
contre lorsque le coût des intrants
augmente
les
manufacturiers sont tentés à réduire les
quantités simplement parce que on veut
pas perdre des parts de marché plus
facile de réduire les quantités que
d'augmenter des prix tout simplement on
le vécu en 2008 lorsque les denrées
avaient augmenté en couple vraiment il y
avait une explosion ça a été la même
chose en 2022 c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle davantage
ces temps-ci parce qu'on voit vraiment
qu'il y a plusieurs catégories qui ont
été affectés même même dans le frais là
on voit que certains qu'on a qui ont été
réduits dans les fraises du Québec là on
en a parlé plutôt là au printemps alors
on voit vraiment que la situation d'une
stratégie qui prend de l'ampleur ben oui
les fraises un bon exemple c'est tout
petit puis le prix
donc mais quand vous dites c'est
cyclique est-ce qu'on rem la quantité à
m'emmener
en fait non je pense qu'on réduit
si on augmente les quantités par après
les années 90 on a vu quelques cas parce
que c'était on avait les ménages il y
avait plus de gens là aujourd'hui il y a
une tendance vers la baisse de plus en
plus de gens qui vivent seuls il y a des
ménages à deux personnes alors la
rééducation à commode certaines
personnes mais dans la pour la grande
majorité des cas surtout avec une
inflation à 10% à l'épicerie là les gens
du gèrent mal la régulation puis on peut
comprendre pourquoi mais il y a un autre
problème que j'aimerais soulever avec
vous monsieur Royce vous permettez
Canada nous on voit pas vraiment comment
on considère l'impact l'influence de la
résiliation sur l'inflation qu'on publie
à chaque mois autrement dit ce que
j'essaie de vous dire c'est que
peut-être il est possible qu'on
sous-estime l'inflation du matin au
Canada en raison de la réutilisation
c'est exactement
exactement monsieur Charlebois merci
beaucoup on va se reparler de ça merci
au revoir au revoir